after 12 years of teaching in the
computer science domain and motivating
my students to follow their passion i
finally got an opportunity to do the
same when my sister asked me to join her
startup hi my name is sharmla and i'm
the co-founder at transform automations
india private limited i did post
graduate program in digital marketing
with simply learn in collaboration with
purdue university while i enjoyed my
work being my own boss at my company
initially we faced a few difficulties
being a bootstrapped startup we had to
outsource our digital marketing work
which was crucial for creating and
establishing our brand it did work well
initially but soon we started facing
issues where the agency and we had
different ideas which ultimately
affected the output i decided to take
digital marketing work of my company
under my control but i had no prior
knowledge and while searching i got to
know about simply learned scores i chose
this course because it had a very good
comprehensive course content i saw good
reviews and spoke to my friends about
the same i got a positive response about
the fact and the certificate and the
alumni status from purdue university was
another driving factor my learning
experience was very good and engaging i
was highly impressed with well
structured curriculum and live
interactive classes learning through
projects gave me a good understanding
on topics such as seo
web analytics and social media marketing
which were very helpful in optimizing
our company's product reach the course
made me understand the true potential of
targeted marketing and help me to scale
my company's growth now i am able to
take calculated approach in resolving
problems the certification was a great
boost to me when i needed it the course
covered all the topics that i needed to
become an expert now i am confident that
i can lead my company's marketing team
while we reach new heights i believe
that commitment and hard work are
important for achieving success
upskilling from a right place is crucial
for one's personal and professional
growth keep learning and success is
guaranteed